i've been ignoring this new blog
of donald trump's for many weeks because
he's posting daily trash to it
of no meaning significance and often
even
related to topics that are not remotely
newsworthy it's basically the last gasps
for attention from a guy who is really
desperate for attention
but banned for many social media
platforms but yesterday i came to you
and i said
sirs in my audience the civil
investigation into the trump
organization being undertaken by the a.g
of new york
leticia james has now become a criminal
investigation that was the news
yesterday a major change there are now
multiple criminal investigations going
on into donald trump's organization
one being done by manhattan d.a sai
vance jr
the other by new york ag leticia james
and my instinct yesterday was
trump's going to go nuts trump's going
to go absolutely
unhinged as a result of this so i went
over
to donald j trump.com desk which is his
blog
and trump put out almost like a full
page of breathless run-on sentences
attacking everyone half the post is in
scare quotes and you have to see it to
believe it
i'm going to try to read some of it
but i can't do all of it because i'm
going to run out of breath okay so
here is some of what trump wrote in
reaction to now being under two
two criminal probes here we go buckle up
i have just learned through leaks in the
mainstream media that after being under
investigation from the time i came down
the escalator five and a half years ago
including the fake russia-russia-russia
hoax the two-year 48 million dollar no
collusion molar witch hunt impeachment
hoax number one impeachment hoax number
two and others that the democrat new
york attorney general has informed my
organization that their investigation
is no longer just a civil matter but
also potentially a criminal
investigation working with the manhattan
district attorney's office
that's one sentence my friends okay
trump goes on to say
there is nothing more corrupt than an
investigation that is in desperate
search of a crime but make no mistake
that is exactly what is happening here
the attorney general of new york
literally campaigned on prosecuting
donald trump even before she knew
anything about me
she said that if elected she would use
her office to look into every aspect of
my real estate dealings
she swore that she would definitely sue
me
she boasted on video that she would be
and i quote a real pain in the ass
she declared just wait until i'm in the
attorney general's office and i've got
my eyes on trump tower
she also promised that if elected she
would join with law enforcement and
other attorney generals dude that's
that's
that should be attorneys general across
this nation and removing this president
from office
and it's important that everyone
understand that the days of donald trump
are coming to an end
the attorney general made each of these
statements not after having had an
opportunity to actually look at the
facts but before she was even elected
before she had even seen a shred of
evidence
this is something that happens in failed
third world countries but not the united
states
if you can run for a prosecutor's office
pledging to take out your enemies and be
elected to that job bipartisan voters
who wish to enact political retribution
then we are no longer a free
constitutional democracy
likewise the district attorney's office
has been going after me for years based
on a lying discredited low life who was
not listened to or given credibility by
other prosecutorial offices
and sentenced to three years in prison
for lying and other events unrelated to
me
these investigations have also been
going on for years with members and
associates of the trump organization
being viciously attacked harassed and
threatened in order to say anything bad
about the 45th president of the united
states
this would include having to make up
false stories numerous documents all
prepared by large and prestigious
prestigious law and accounting firms
have been examined and many hours of
testimony have been taken from many
people
some of whom i have not seen in years
all right there's there's like pages and
pages and pages and
it ends with if these prosecutors
focused on real issues crime would be
obliterated and new york
would be great and free again
um extraordinarily triggered i mean just
completely and totally off the rails
and just imagine what will happen
if donald trump or more likely
associates or whatever
were to be charged it would be
completely
off the rails and i don't know how
scared trump personally is
but there are a lot of people around
donald trump that are very
very scared right now because of now two
criminal investigations
into the trump organization and so i
don't know how much more we're going to
continue hearing from donald trump we we
spoke already about how
uh rudy giuliani has the walls closing
in around him as well
and trump seems to have made the
decision that he wants to head for the
hills
and have nothing to do with defending
rudy or speaking out or helping rudy
raise money or any of it which he has
been asked to do repeatedly
so it's certainly possible that the fear
is actually starting to reach donald
trump at this point in time at the same
time the counterbalance to that is that
people
we've said this before people as
narcissistic as donald trump
tend to think nobody can touch me and
that is something which may
keep trump in a sort of uh fantasy world
where he's not worried at all now for
his sake
it's probably not going to ever lead to
charges against donald trump as i've
said before and it's certainly not going
to lead to prison time so
maybe trump isn't crazy not to be afraid
if he's not afraid
but triggered he is and i would only
expect as these investigations build
and if rudy giuliani is charged this guy
is going to absolutely explode the likes
of which we have probably not yet seen
we'll have more on this including donald
trump's multi-page single paragraph rant
it's one paragraph but it's many pages
on his blog on the david pakman show
instagram
which you can find at davidpakmanshow on
instagram
davidpakmanshow on instagram you can
also find me
on instagram not as good as the david
pakman show account i try
but i'm not nearly as good at posting uh
david.pacman you can find me on
instagram we are going to speak
to bill share after this brief break and
then i will do my mask rant a little bit
later on in the show
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
and you'll get 10 percent off
all nebia products when you go to
nebia.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
the link is right underneath this video